[Musique]
ces trois enseignantes musulmane
installée au québec depuis des années
ont des positions bien campés sur le
port du voile
entrée merci defla je m'appelle 2000 ha
d'ar je suis prof de français le 10 et
des jeunes de laval et j'habite à
montréal depuis 20 ans je m'appelle
leila ben salem je suis originaire
d'algérie
j'habite au québec depuis 37 ans
actuellement je fais de la suppléance
dans une école secondaire à montréal je
m'appelle la laisse bête je suis
technicienne en éducation spécialisée
je suis originaire d'algérie et j'habite
le québec depuis 18 ans vous êtes
musulmane vous êtes dans le milieu de
l'enseignement mais vous ne portait pas
le voile pourquoi parce que ça fait pas
partie de mes convictions et
moi en enseignant j'ai toujours pensé
qu'on était un modèle pour nos élèves et
que c'est pas un genre de modèle que
j'aimerais leur donner j'étais
enseignante en algérie et se voit le n'a
jamais existé donc il n'a jamais fait
partie ni de notre culture et encore
moins de notre religion
on allait à l'école à l'université on
était sans voile donc le voile est
arrivé avec la révolution iranienne en
donc je suis ça me fait un petit peu le
sourire de cette identité qui n'est avec
un mouvement politique se voilent qu'est
ce qu'il représente exactement le voile
pour moi et pour les fans qui veut
s'affranchir pour les femmes libres et
les féministes
c'est le drapeau de l'international des
frères musulmans
c'est une idéologie islamiste
c'est du fascisme pour moi c'est
vraiment le porte étendard des
islamistes parce que c' est étroitement
associée aux islamises tous les endroits
où ils sont arrivés toutes les régions
qu'ils ont colonisé en essayant de
s'installer
c'était la première exigence envers les
femmes comment vous réagissez à
justement cette phrase-là le voile c'est
notre identité
on n'enlèvera pas c'est pas le voile qui
va vous donner une identité
c'est ce que vous êtes c'est ce que vous
désirez transmettre à vos élèves c'est
ça qui est important parce que il faut
arriver avec cette loi là ici au québec
je trouve qu'il est très important quand
je suis à l'école les enfants n'ont pas
à savoir qu'elle et quelles sont mes
croyances religieuses quelles sont mes
croyances politiques quelles sont mes
croyances spirituelles
absolument pas est-ce que ce projet de
loi 21 va assez loin pour vous est ce
que c'est vraiment la bonne chose à
faire adopter en fait pour moi c'est un
projet extrêmement important parce que
je pense que c'est l'aboutissement enfin
de la révolution tranquille des années
je dirais qu'il ne va pas assez loin
mais je trouve que le gouvernement a été
assez assez modéré assez assez
intelligente pour 10 rebonds
c'est un socle minimum nous allons nous
entendre là dessus et nous allons
travailler pour cela
moi je trouve que son projet doit être
plus loin que ça parce qu'il a mis de
côté les écoles privées je suis désolé
même les écoles privées on doit à
protéger les enfants
pas seulement par rapport à la voile
mais par rapport comment on gère les
écoles religieuses pour moi en tant
qu'enseignante à l'école il ya un nid
synagogues ni mosquée n'est église mois
le sanctuaire de l'école c'est le
cerveau la laïcité
qu'est ce que c'est pour eux c'est de
permettre le mieux vivre ensemble tout
simplement parce que c'est grâce à cette
neutralité de l'état et de ses employés
qu'on peut apprendre à vivre ensemble
sans aucune distinction
et puis la religion ma foi bien ça fait
partie de la sphère privée
il faut pas qu'il y ait intrusion du
religieux dans les affaires de l'état
tout ce qui est institutionnel doit être
incarnée avec des personnes qui
n'affichent pas leur religion
il a la majorité wahou fonce tu as la
majorité c'est maintenant ou jamais